(bright music)
- I see my work as woven
into the fabric of cities.
These soft fibers move and
adapt to wind and light and rain,
and they are a way of being;
they are about interconnectedness.
I'm Janet Echelman, I'm an artist.
I bring sculpture and form and
light into the public realm,
so that we can literally change the spaces
that we live in, in cities.
My sculpture has traveled
to five continents.
It takes an incredible team to create
one of these sculptures.
I am working with computer
scientists and artisans,
and aeronautical and structural engineers
all over the world.
This part is hanging the
way we want it to hang,
down there.
My studio is where we incubate ideas.
Some of my newest work I'm
using data sets from science,
whether it's human action or
an earthquake and tsunami,
to reveal our relationship with the world;
and then I just start sketching,
whether it's with a pen or paintbrush.
Then we start to model
it in three dimensions
in the computer, and we
also make physical models.
They begin as raw fiber that
is braided into twine and rope,
put on to bobbins, and
loomed using machines,
and the ropes are spliced by hand.
To take the work and
install it in the city
is a whole 'nother set of artistry.
The peace comes together as
a single sewn garment for the city.
My work is about the
dynamic nature of life,
and it's always unfolding.
During the day the colors of the sculpture
change slightly as sunlight changes.
At night I'm projecting colored light
that is very slowly, gradually changing.
It's never the same piece,
and you and the person
you come to see it with
might have completely
different experiences.
The work invites people to engage with it.